satellite images show a buildup of
russian military activity at the
ukrainian border in recent weeks there
is concern that russia is actually
getting ready to invade its smaller
neighbor the kremlin denies this
but u.s intelligence revealed that
moscow has drawn up plans for a military
invasion of ukraine that could involve
around 175 000 troops as soon as next
year the meeting with putin i was very
straightforward if in fact
he invades ukraine there will be severe
consequences
ukraine has been trying to join western
organizations like nato and the eu but
this is at odds with what russia wants
which is to have influence over the
country
the u.s and russia have recently
expelled diplomats over cyber crime and
clashed over energy supplies and a
migrant crisis on the border between
belarus and poland after the summit
between president biden and president
putin in june there was a glimmer of
hope that the countries might set a
different course but again there has
been this struggle
here's how the clash between the us and
russia over ukraine is worsening an
already tense relationship
russia invaded ukraine and seized the
ukrainian peninsula of crimea after the
country staged a pro-western revolution
in 2014.
ever since then russian president
vladimir putin has tried to prevent
ukraine's drift towards the west ukraine
has for a long time wanted to join nato
and putin has voiced anger over the us
and its allies financial and military
support of the country
the kremlin has made very clear that
they feel that any kind of deployment of
nato troops in eastern ukraine which
would be russia's western borders
would be a threat and for russia that is
a red line
the key question would be especially in
relation to the russian buildup of
troops on the border
how far will the u.s and nato be willing
to go in order to protect ukraine
while the u.s and nato have no
obligation to help ukraine the biden
administration has threatened serious
sanctions against russia and said it
wouldn't tolerate another invasion like
the one in 2014
washington has also said it would help
protect ukraine's sovereignty but press
kiev to reform internal issues like
corruption
tensions between russia and the u.s have
been building for a while
the us recently imposed sanctions and
ordered the expulsion of more than 50
russian diplomats by june 30th based on
allegations of cyber attacks and u.s
election interference
moscow retaliated by doing the same
ordering the removal of several u.s
embassy personnel from russia by next
year this is a kind of tit for tat what
they call mirror measures taken against
the u.s who they say has basically
violated diplomatic norms so there is
definitely this this back and forth this
diplomatic tug of war if you wish in a
call with putin in december biden warned
that if russia made any moves in ukraine
the us would prevent the completion of
russia's nordstream ii pipeline which
washington sees as a threat to european
energy independence
the pipeline would transport natural gas
from russia to europe and be a huge
source of energy revenue for moscow
russia is a major exporter of gas to
europe and an important channel runs
through belarus
belarusian president alexander
lukashenko recently threatened to
disrupt that flow of energy after the eu
imposed sanctions on the country over a
migrant crisis in november on its border
with poland
western leaders have accused russia of
helping exacerbate the crisis a claim
that moscow denies
earlier on in biden's presidency
washington had wanted to establish a
closer relationship with kremlin
but as tensions escalate over ukraine
political analysts say the two aren't
making much progress towards that goal a
lot of it can boil down to the fact that
you know russia feels that
it has been ignored both countries have
said of course we do not want this
confrontation
but it seems as though a lot of the
times it's one step forward two steps
back as they each try to maintain
influence and not want to be seen as the
weaker between the two sides